this is the bismillah alhamdulillah
Salam alaikum peace be unto you we are
going to be answering some of your
questions we have a special Q&A session
here we wait for an individual who's
qualified to answer these questions and
we had to wait a little bit we got
someone in the studio he's the Vice
President Al Maghrib he's also involved
with the Unga online where you can
submit your questions
dr. Sheikh will leave a SUNY special Q&A
section here in the D so don't go
nowhere
Salaam aleikum peace be unto you that
I'm still our cat how are you chef very
good from the lady how's everything with
you
excellent excellent under love back here
for another episode people go to the
Deen show calm you have your own private
section there where people can see some
of the previous shows that we've done
and we're gonna get right into the topic
Q&A session with dr. Sheikh will leave a
Sunni I'm Jay online yes I'm John Wayne
calm this is where you have a group of
scholars here in America will people
they can go reliable who give the
verdicts from the verbatim word of God
and the Sunnah or the last final measure
yes yeah so you you're involved there so
we're gonna we're going to read some
some questions that some of the people
they have they write in and hopefully
from these questions people can somewhat
you know relate to it and these might be
situations that they're also going
through so it can be a general benefit
for the masses of people so getting into
our our next question the person asks I
believe it's a male he said I need some
advice
he's I've explained the importance of
the the the modest way of dress in Islam
which is the hijab we know as Muslims
this is something that's required he
said to my wife for years now but she
seems not to take the issue seriously
she's a good person she prays but but
won't put the hijab she fears it will
upset her family you know their Muslim -
it says by name but it seems like not by
action what we call Ramadan listen she's
talking about her or when someone dies
they'll bring out any mom to read the
Quran you know this is how much they
implement the deen he says so she fears
upsetting them please give me some
advice we have a daughter also and I
fear she might follow in her footsteps
if she doesn't set a good Islamic
example for the child I need some advice
talk to us he says
okay well I'm saying talk to you but
he's saying yes first of all thank you
for having me again you shall Thank You
ed email hospital ah bless you and bless
your effort and accept from all of us as
for this brother my advice to you first
of all I ask you to always show your
love and support to your wife as being
your wife don't be mad if she may be
lacking this area because interested
from your question she's a good woman
she's a great woman
be grateful thankful to La Strada and I
think through love and good relationship
with your wife I'm sure that you will
have a good influence on her in this
area don't give up and don't change your
feelings towards her that's number one
number two I want you also to ask a loss
of Chanukah a day and night in your
prayer I know a lot of people and like
him and you in your situation a lot of
good brothers good friends of mine
unfortunately their wives they don't
dress properly they don't wear hijab all
the time so what I will tell you the
same thing I've been telling them preto
lost my daughter ask him
always from the bottom of your heart
that Allah open her heart to see the
truth the way you see it as well
so that's number two number three and as
far I can I can tell that he his wife
knows that she has she need to work a
job but she doesn't want to upset her
family one thing I will tell basically
this sister what you really need to care
about the feeling that you care about
the most is a lost panettone how I lost
mat Allah sees you is he's pleased with
what you do or he's upset with what you
do I think that's the most important
thing in life what is my relationship
with the Creator before my relationship
with any creation he is has the one the
right over me over anybody else anybody
else and I want to tell you something
Monrovia Lara and whoever Allah will be
pleased with him he will make other
people East with that person
if Allah pleased with you he will let
other to be pleased with you as well
and whoever allah subhanaw taala is
displeased with no one will be basically
pleased with him so if you really want
to please your family please unlost para
Tallis verse and i'll tell you your
family will accept it maybe in the
beginning they feel something strange
and not used to it but down on the road
they were accepted they were respected
because it's not something i made it up
or you made it up it's something Allah
our Creator he have chosen for you and
he didn't choose this he didn't ordain
this he didn't legislate this for you
for no good reason it's for the best for
you and for for for you in this worldly
life and in the hereafter as well so
what I wanted to do sister to tell your
parents why are you doing this you're
doing this because you pleasing Allah
subhana WA Ta'ala planet honor order you
to do and also because you don't want to
yeah I mean make a loss man Tyler angry
at you or you want to suffer the
consequences of disobeying him the
Prophet SAW solemn said there is two
kind of people among the people of
hellfire I haven't seen them and he said
cassy at an area a woman who dress but
in the same times they not dressing one
of the meaning of this hadith the ulema
said that she covered part of her body
that's supposed to cover and she doesn't
cover the rest and which is basically
that what he some woman will do and they
don't wear hijab and also the Prophet
SAW solemn said our Rafaela to physi
neti ha he said that the woman who go
outside showing her beauties in front of
pub in the public places in front of men
or not related to her the Prophet SAW
solemn said when she walks she walk
while Allah is angry at her so he if you
have AB Allah that Allah spittle is
angry at her so my dear sister eonni
take this issue seriously the issue of
wearing hijab is not just a recommended
something Rajab it's not just not
wearing hijab is just
ass and it's one of the serious sins in
a snap and I think you inshallah with
determinations and trust in allah
subhanaw taala you can take that steps
you can walk with your heads up high and
you have full trust in allah Spinetta
allah the t will change their attitude
towards you and if you get a little bit
of tests a little bit of challenge be
patient and a loss per dollar reward you
for it let's take a break with that same
we'll be right back with more doctor che
gelida suni here the Disha
I started asking deeper questions the
question I want people to really ask
themselves is when you come back from a
night on the town
you've been drinking you've been boozing
you've been dancing then you're hanging
out with girls guys whatever number one
did you improve yourself is human being
number two did you contribute anything
to the betterment of humanity the
amazing thing is is that the most
advanced studies in psychology about
human happiness show that these are the
two key factors in making people
profoundly happy I take five minutes out
of my day and prayed to the Creator and
none of the creations and I feel a deep
internal peace and I still have my
normal life
back here on the Dean show with a
special Q&A session and if we don't ask
your questions here today you can go to
I'm J online
I'm submitted it's where a group of
scholars came together to help the
Muslims living in America with some of
the many challenges and questions they
might have
yes and what you're one of them yes
masha'Allah okay so I just want to spend
just just a little bit more time on this
question is that okay yeah I want to ask
you now because we you said you also
have friends in a similar situation and
many of us do also so now is is the
brother also is this important on him
because if he doesn't pay too much
attention to this and he lets it go
let's say he tried a little bit he's not
consistent he's got to be merciful nice
kind and obviously not oppressive and
whatnot like you said but if he's not
consistent he just gives up and then he
lets the wife do what she wants and now
she's creating a fit now therefore the
me is he gonna carry the sin no you
don't carry the sin no right everybody
responsible for his own actions okay as
long as you give the advice you give
naseeha you tell her about what would
you what Allah so Allah said is right
and and then the end of the day it's her
call and I lost my thought I will hold
her accountable for her action but you
will not be sinful for that so what is
too much when does he like say okay I
told her like say the person told her
once twice or does it is a lifetime just
continuingly
advising in a nice way you know honey I
love you more can you you know do this
Allah will love you more you just keep
doing it yes but I think the person need
to work a lot on is strengthening the
relationship between his wife and Allah
believe me the moment that her Eman
would be strong she will take that
decision she'll put that hijab on you
know I was teaching a course this
weekend and here in Chicago yeah about
[ __ ] off love so I had three girls in
the class they decide to wear hijab
after the class and this said we've been
debating all these days well hamdulillah
after attending the class basically with
almagro class the
for two weekends we've been coming would
be listening we're ready to make that
decision now and I was so happy because
they walk into me and and one of them at
least walk to me and she told me that
very clearly said I want to thank you
I'm now ready to put the hijab I took
that decision now it's like I'm not
gonna take it off I've been putting it
since I started the class so you can see
it in her eyes that this is the right
moment she's thinking about it for a
while but something hit her heart she
attended the class she listened to her
advice they diverse maybe a story
something strike her and she made that
decision so I'm trying to say he need to
work and her and his wife to strengthen
her relationship with Allah SWA Dada so
it will be ready for that
you know a lot of woman also feels shy
because as you know when a sister wears
hijab she stands out in history more
than me and you and anyone else yes so a
lot of them they don't like this
attention and in the society here so
they're scared from putting the hijab
but when you tell them no you don't
stand out in a like a sore thumb or
anything like that you stand out as a
most beautiful yeah and yet ham did a
lot of spected here and he won because
you obey I lost my heart you put this
because you're making a declaration that
I'm putting it because Allah wanted me
to do that and I'm submitting myself to
my Lords yeah well can this be now we
know we're tested you know as Muslims
were you know we're facing the test
every day can this be one of them maybe
biggest you know a test that she's going
through but if she passes she sir comes
this that this can land her in in
paradise absolutely the more things are
difficult to do and used to end up for
it and you do it the more your adjure
will be the reward will be Allah will
multiply that he work for you and at the
same time we know Allah is the most
loving the most merciful he can forgive
but don't you open up yourself to you
know the anger of Allah if you just
continue disobeying him absolutely well
put myself in a position like that it's
like 50/50 candy you know I might
forgive he might not we didn't know yet
yeah I know that even a lot of sisters
they don't wear hijab and they are
wonderful sister there
Muslims they do a lot of good things I
don't underestimate your roles at all I
have I have my community sister who not
maybe wearing hijab they very active
they contribute a lot and we as a Muslim
community I think we should give them
opportunity to do to contribute to work
but I believe also my heart the more she
will do things the good deed like this
she will eventually insha'Allah reach
the level that she can make that
decision and one day you will be
surprised she will come and she will
bring the hijab and all those people
that many of us we fear they're not
going to be in the grave with us are
they just us there absolutely and that's
finished we got one shot okay so yeah
this is out of the love that we're doing
can we love our sisters don't we we do
and we want the best friend absolutely
I'm do la do la we're gonna move on we
spent a little extra time because we
feel this is a very very important issue
and we want people to benefit from it so
we have people like yourself to help us
and we're moving on to something here
the the person wants to know now they
want to know about what are some of the
benefits are praying the night prayer
and what time does it start okay so what
time is it officially the night prayer
and can I do just one unit only or how
many do I have to do when I pray the
night prayer says you know it's hard for
me to keep my eyes open that late at
night so the benefits and what are some
of the rules of it and you know do I
just can do one unit how many do I have
to do before I can go back to bed do I
also this one want to add it's not a
part of it but does a person actually
also then they have to sleep many people
think you have to sleep then wake up or
can you just and say you're up at 1:00
in the morning or 12 does that consider
night prayer please answer this okay the
night prayer which is a volunteer prayer
start after you pray Asia start after
you praying as you sow doesn't matter
any normal situation with pressure on
time and after that the night prayer
time start all the way to the fed your
prayer then when it's cold so you have
all this period this period of time to
do the night prayer you can do it in the
beginning and you can do it in the
middle you can do in the end of this
period term you can do it any time you
want any time you want and the way you
do it as the Prophet SAW solemn said so
- lately matthan and matthan a night
prayer is to rocket rocket rocket then
you end it with one then you end it with
one if a person cannot offer anything
except one that's fine because in Ibiza
solemn said outer door I will be either
pray with her even it is one but the
best way to do three raka at the minimum
this is the best way because he said -
then you add one two three three
requires three or a class three you know
as he said in his question or her
question I don't know so basically
that's the night prayer you if you know
that you can work up in the last third
of the night that will be the best time
how would you basically calculate the
last third of the night you start from
the sunset to the sunrise and you look
at this time you divided by three so the
last third night the last third of the
night will be whatever time let's say
it's from one o'clock over eight to five
for example or two for a am worth of
federal programs that will be the best
time to pray or night prayer the best
time to pray or night prayer because the
Prophet assalam said this is where Allah
accept more the draw everyone awake at
that time the Prophet assalam told about
one of his companion he is the best one
if he makes the army late if he prays in
the night you know night prayer was
obligated on Muslim in the beginning of
Islam then Allah abrogate this and he
made it only volunteer otherwise in the
beginning I was obligated every Muslim
obligated to woke up in the night and to
pray but Allah made it easy and US and
only made five days five prayers
obligated on us when you stand up beside
before I lost Rantala in the night he
just declaring that you love him more
than anything else more than anything
that you desire and a lot makalah
finally insert two such day after he
mentioned those who woke up in the night
and leave the bed and they pray he
immediately said Fallot M&F soon Malik
fara home in Parvati are just there and
be McHenry I'm alone no one can imagine
the amount of free
or waiting for you because of what you
used to do in this world in life what
you used to offer and one of it no doubt
is offering this night prayer so when
you have like things are getting tough
and rough
this can be an antidote to your problem
getting up at that one third of the
night and praying absolutely absolutely
no doubt I know one sister she she had a
she's a Russian sister okay she is her
husband and this while ago they went to
Russia to have her passport pictures but
she wouldn't hear hijab and they said no
we have to take off your hijab and she's
a new Muslim she said I'm not gonna take
off my hijab and her husband told her
they had a lot of trouble there so do
you want to go back to their where they
live in Dubai so basically her husband
told her you know what just take the
picture she said no I'm not taking the
picture and she said this brother was
telling me a story he she wake me up in
the night and she said wake up and she
pray every night he says every day we go
to the passport office to do the
passport they reject us
so she wake me up and she said look I
was reading in the night and I come
across this verse what is it in social
para or may yet tequila edge 11 Maharaja
whoever have taqwa worship Allah Allah
will give him an exit she wakes me up
and she let me read this and he pray
with her
he said well Liza next day when I went
to the passport office we went to the
same exact officer all of a sudden this
general called me and he said come here
I see you coming every day what you guys
have here I said we know we have the
passport we want to renew it he took it
he sign it in one hour we got the
passport with her picture with the hijab
and we left that's what they're mean
laters hamdulillah we right back with
more he and the Deen show when people
say that the Quran is irrelevant I say
how can we become irrelevant Obama
rain is just like revelation and the
Quran is a living book it's not a dead
book it's not an ancient book it's a
living book for all time because God
knows the past and the future and so
it's up to us as Muslims to take the
verses of the Quran the values in the
principle of the Quran and to relate
them to finding solutions for
contemporary issues and circumstances
back here on the Deen show with dr.
Sheikh will leave the Sunni and we're
gonna continue on answering some of
these questions that hopefully
insha'Allah can be a benefit for
everyone who's listening all over the
globe all over the world we're gonna
continue on then we've got time for one
more
okay inshallah okay the the brothers
asking he says he needs some advice on
how to deal with his wife that you know
she's a great woman up until that time
at a month just called what are the PMS
okay I say that yes is that okay yeah
you know it's that time at a month and
then you know it becomes like somewhat
of a living hell it's very difficult he
needs some advice
he needs some advice what could he do
should leave the house should he run to
you know take a vacation no first of all
you have to understand that woman go
through a lot of cycles and difference
of emotions ups and downs especially
during her period basically a lot of
hormones things going on in her body you
know she might a little bit act
differently than normal
what you need to do you need to
understand us and not to be angry or
frustrated with her and to give her room
you know to give a little her space I
don't mean by that to leave the house or
anything but you can easily asking her
what she wants don't try to hurt her
maybe at that time just communicate with
her talk about what she wants what she
likes what how can I make this period of
time easier in you how can I be I need
to be maybe a little bit more sensitive
and what I say to my wife during this
period
of time and that's what good husband's
do they just asked her why how am i best
love you and and be the best to you and
the Prophet SAW solemn said the best
among you to their family are the best
among you so I will advise you to open a
line of communication with you arrive
about this issue now on this issue when
a woman is going through this is she
allowed what can she do to temper this
light can she we know she can't pray all
right so this is even more difficult for
her I mean cuz she read the Quran could
she make vicar what can she do I'm
hosting absolutely first of all if she
gets so nervous and angry the Prophet
SAW Sullivan told us to say oh the
villain astrology or Allah protect me
from the shape on that's one two she can
make with o even if she doesn't pray
this will take the anger away also the
Prophet SAW solemn said if you're so
angry sit down in a and he said be
sitting and he's still angry just lay
down in another word just cut the
conversation don't involve and doubt an
argument if he's so angry just cut it
off you know said lay down just do
something else and also one more thing
that you basically if you're so angry
like this and it's something nominal you
start making vicar or law Spinetta odd
even while you are you have your menses
or even really reciting some of the
verses of the Quran and if it's
something out of control you might be a
good idea for you to see a counselor and
to talk to talk to her about this is is
taking any prescription xanax or any of
these things that calm a person down is
this allowed in Islam this has to be
through if the doctor said it's not
harmful and it's it's good for her yeah
it's a lot okay we're out of time but
any call I mean we're really excited
that people you know people are taking
the time they want to know they want to
learn absolutely saying that the rat
race of life is not giving them peace
and contentment but what's gonna give
them peace is submitting to the one God
the creator of the heavens and earth
doing Islam so what advice do you have
for those people now that you know they
really want to change their lives they
have so many questions some people might
have some doubts how did they continue
on this this journey you know you always
ask yourself when you look around you
and you see everything exist in
this work it's for a purpose there's a
reason behind it there is a benefit
behind its existence so I think the
question that you have to ask yourself
what is the benefit of me being here
what's the purpose of being here what
I'm doing that basically what's the
purpose of my existence in my life I'm
fulfilling this destiny or not you know
I live in Texas okay and I have a
neighbor who had basically a hunting dog
yes and he'd take this hunting dog every
weekend basically to to out outdoor the
moment and he he put his truck okay and
taking that the dog basically to the to
this farm or ranch this dog in the
backyard jumping up and down and so
excited why because this dog was not
made to stay in the background of
somebody's house yeah this dog was made
to be running in the field in open area
so this dogs so excited because he's
gonna meet the destiny and the purpose
fulfill the purpose of his creation you
know what this is exactly get us if we
don't meet the purpose of our creation
we just locked in that and in a small
place in my daily life and my busy life
I didn't I'm not fulfilling what I'm
created for and the only time you get
that rush that excitement that happiness
that basically feeling when you start
fulfilling the destiny or destiny you're
fulfilling the purpose of your existence
which is to worship Allah span of time
and to submit yourself to him at that
moment biovolt tastes different things
will be look completely different
because at that moment you met your
destiny that that lost Maradona they
have prepared for you great advice great
advice thank you once again Shea for
being with us may God Almighty Allah
reward you thank you and thank you for
joining us on another episode of the
Deen show and for our non-muslims
brothers in humanity you see how we
tackle these issues we see how we answer
the questions that people have from day
to day
snob is a solution for all your problems
it wasn't something that was just for
back then is for today yesterday and
tomorrow and if you liked what we had to
talk about here today continue to tune
in to the Dean show even you can get a
free Quran which is the verbatim Word of
God just got to call the number on the
screen 1-866 to and tune in here every
week until next time peace be unto you